[Music]
h-how'd if you heard about this story
but earlier this week a woman at an
Atlanta Airport was detained by TSA so
they could search her afro for search
her search her afro for weapons and
explosives yeah and I was watching TV
this morning and I saw an interview with
the woman she seemed really upset but
personally as I was watching the
interview I thought I think the TSA is
just doing its job
check out my hair is Isis Brantley on a
trip home to Dallas this week says she
made it through an airport security
checkpoint with TSA officers chased her
down hey you hey you ma'am ma'am stop
stop she agreed to let them search her
hair for weapons
she started petting my hair and I was
like in tears at that point as she
[Applause]